all righty so we're here to discuss
best-selling book in America Robin to
Angelo's white fragility it is a truly
awful book on every level I'm gonna go
through it in detail with you we're
going to problem spot it and note that
basically it's just a cult manual it
really is a call manual we'll get to all
of that in just a second first just want
to let you know that this video and
videos like it are brought to you by our
sponsor is over a TRACON they are indeed
spectacular go get yourself a pair of
rate constants you listen to content
like this alrighty so let's talk about
this truly awful cult book it is a cult
book the only way to describe why for
joe aided by Robin D'Angelo is that this
is basically a book by a cult leader who
is going to cleanse you of your thetans
your racists thetans
yeah you you have all of these racist
thetans they've clogged up your soul and
they were put into a volcano long ago
and now they've exploded they've coded
your soul the only way to get rid of the
racist thetans is to let Robin to
Angelou educate you in your racism
racism you didn't even know that you had
if you deny that you have you're even
more racist than you were before the
book is just loaded with problems it is
absolutely insane I mean it's an insane
book they're a bunch of folks who are
liberal by the way who have reviewed
this book and found it to be completely
insane because you don't actually have
to be conservative to spot absolute
bullcrap when you see it and this book
is just that I broke it down into seven
categories of suckiness so there are
seven categories that really kind of
this book breaks down into they are
historical nonsense so her take on
American history is just obscenely
ridiculous and then there is the her
bizarre redefinition of racism so she
redefines the term racism to mean this
thing out there that she can label you
with even though you know you're not a
racist and then there is a third
category of stupidity and that is
ripping on American systems so all
systems of America are inherently bad it
must be ripped it down to the ground
then there is the fourth problem which
is the arrogance of white centrality the
idea that the only voices that matter in
America our voices like Robin to
Angelo's only white woke leftist like
Robin de Angelo matter because she is
better than you she has moral more moral
authority she's been a white person than
you have for white and she is more
intelligent than you if you are black
and you require her as a white Savior in
order to fix your life if you are a
black person I mean she she's fairly
explicit about a lot of this stuff in
the book v problem she treats black
people as absolute tokens she does not
treat them as fellow human beings who
think and act like
human beings she treats them as sort of
an exotic other who react in bizarre
ways that only Robyn D'Angelo sees it's
very weird you get to the biggest
problem of all is the unfalsifiable 'ti
of it the coalition nonsense of it and
and this is I mean if she could have you
at a resort in Latin America drinking
kool-aid she would Robyn D'Angelo the
unfalsifiable 'ti and the cult ish
insanity of this book are beyond the
pale and then finally the insane
examples that's my favorite part she has
a bunch of kind of personal stories of
stuff she's done in her diversity
training she has paid tens of thousands
of dollars to lecture woke white people
at companies and supposedly make them
less erases but it's weird because when
she walks away people seem to be more
pissed off than they were before she
came but that's just a sign of their own
white fragility and defensiveness so
we'll get to all of those things okay so
let us begin at the beginning with her
take on American history now as I've
said before there are really really a
lot of bad things in American history
and you don't have to make light of bad
things in American history in order to
still say that America is an incredible
nation with tremendous founding
principles that we failed to live up to
and the story of America is getting
better over time and broadening the
rights guaranteed in the founding to
more and more people over time in
consonance with universal principles you
don't have to whitewash any of American
history in order to say that according
to Robin to Angelou however American
history really did not exist up until
Robyn D'Angelo wrote this book and her
take on American history is so bizarre
it's it's completely disconnected so
I'll give you an example she says in
this book quote women were denied the
right to vote until 1920 black women
were denied access to that right until
1965 so if you just read that you would
think the black women were denied the
vote until 1965 that's not true black
women were given the vote at the same
time the white women were given the vote
namely in in 1920 now it did require the
Voting Rights Act to ensure that black
Americans were given access to the
ballot box but she says this like three
or four different times this 1965 idea
that black women not allowed to vote
until no black Americans were basically
discriminated against until the end of
Jim Crow and that's that's a minor
example she also gives the example of
Jackie Robinson she suggests that the
way we learned history in America is
deeply wrong because we learned things
like black people who are successful are
outliers
so Jackie Robinson the only reason he
made the major leagues is because he was
the only black player deserving of
reaching the major leagues there's not a
single fan of baseball who
ever thought that like literally not a
single family may Jackie Robinson
historic is that he was the first black
ballplayer not that he was the first
good black ballplayer I feel like most
baseball fans are fairly well aware of
this thing called the Negro Leagues
where there were lots of great players
like Josh Gibson and Satchel Paige like
we were all pretty much aware of that
but she has to rewrite history such that
all white people everywhere are bad and
also apparently incredibly stupid again
those are the mild examples listen to
how she characterizes America's history
quote in some ways racism - adaptations
over time are more sinister than
concrete rules such as Jim Crow the
adaptations produce the same outcome
people of color are blocked from moving
forward but have been put in place by a
dominant white society that won't or
can't admit to its beliefs she is
literally saying that the racist
adaptations in America light in American
life are worse since the Civil Rights
Act than the regime of Jim Crow you have
to be patently insane person to believe
this given the the advancements that
black Americans have made since the end
of Jim Crow the growth of the black
middle class the increase in black
college graduates I mean given the fact
that you don't have legal barriers to
entry in the United States anymore to
suggest that in formal structures of
racism are more damaging to black
Americans then you know legalize
structures of racism in the United
States is perfectly insane this is this
may be my favorite a historical quote
this is just again doing the really
taking the narrative that you see so
often and sort of the New York Times
op-ed page where you pick a bad thing
that happened in 1783 and then you go
and it's just the same today and you
just miss all the intervening history
this quote is a real charmer quote there
is a curious satisfaction in the
punishment of black people the smiling
faces of the white crowd picnicking at
lynchings in pasts and the satisfied
approval of white people observing mass
incarceration and execution in the
present so she's literally saying that
white people today who look at the
prison system are exactly the same types
of people who attended lynchings as a
party in 1920 which is crazy there's
another word fat that be crazy that is
nuts
that is nuttiness on a very high level
that is that is just crazy cuz she's a
crazy person okay so that is point
number one is her a crazy view of
American history and this again is tied
in to her crazy definition of American
racism so this gets us to point number
two so normally we define racism as
discrimination against someone based on
race correct
wouldn't that be this
definition of racism racism is when I
treat you differently based on your race
because I have a bad perception of you
because of your race right that is the
definition of racism but not according
to Robin to Angelo
racism is far more than that racism is
in the air
racism surrounds us it binds us
it holds the Galaxy together right she's
the Yoda of racism it's the force that's
all it is quote everyone has prejudices
and discriminates but structures of
oppression go well beyond individuals
well women could be prejudiced and
discriminate against men in individual
interactions women as a group could not
deny men their civil rights so one of
the key aspects of racism according to
Robyn D'Angelo is that racism and this
is a trope on the left is that
discrimination it's not just
discrimination and Prejudice it is
discrimination and Prejudice baked into
systems of power into hierarchies of
power so sure a black person could
discriminate against a white person but
the black person has no power so you're
assuming the problem this is perfectly
circular America is discriminatory right
and the proof that America is
discriminatory is that America is
discriminatory that is the proof that
America is discriminatory is that
America is discriminatory
so it is an identity she's basically
saying that America is discriminatory
because of white people and if you point
to other people who discriminate they
don't count because America is
discriminatory because of white people
and that is the logic that she is using
here so this leads her to insane
contentions like this one whites Hoadley
social and institutional positions in
society to infuse their racial prejudice
into the laws policies practices and
norms of a society in a way that people
of color do not hate now that may have
been true in like 1960 that is certainly
not true today right listen to the rest
of this quote a person of color may
refuse to wait on me if I enter a shop
but people of color cannot pass
legislation that prohibits me and
everyone like me from buying a home in a
certain neighborhood that is literally
forbidden by federal law a white person
cannot pass that legislation either it
is barred by federal law it was made
illegal in the Fair Housing Act of 1968
guys been legal for a really long time
and then they're a bunch of acts that
were designed to actually end redlining
things like the Community Reinvestment
Act of 1977 like there's plenty of
legislation on this has been illegal for
a long time but because she's ignorant
she says this kind of stuff okay then
she gets to this so again she's trying
to redefine
racism so that whiteness is the problem
she says the racial ideology that
circulates in the United States
rationalizes racial hierarchies is the
outcome of a natural order resulting
from either genetics or individual
effort or talent ideologies that obscure
racism is a system of inequality are
perhaps the most powerful racial forces
because once we accept our positions
within racial hierarchies those
positions seem natural and difficult to
question even when we are disadvantaged
by them switch she's suggesting here is
that if you believe in a meritocracy or
that individuals are responsible for
their decisions this is an aspect of
tacit racism right racism has now been
broadened out you don't have to be
personal and she says this over and over
you don't have to be personally racist
or I've done a racist thing in order for
you to be racist as part of a broader
racist system because you are defined by
race in order for her to accomplish this
idea that only white people have power
in the United States which again is an
insanity just beyond pale she says this
this is crazy right quote although rare
individual people of color may be inside
the circles of power Colin Powell
Clarence Thomas Marco Rubio Barack Obama
they support the status quo and do not
challenge racism in any way significant
enough to be threatening did you know
that did you know that Barack Obama just
supported the status quo and didn't
challenge racism ever were you aware of
this you white woke liberals you she
says to say that whiteness is a
standpoint it's to say that a
significant aspect of white identity is
to see oneself as an individual outside
or innocent of race just human in other
words if you're a white person you say
I'm just human and I'm just an
individual and I'm not thinking to
myself is in terms of why person that
just demonstrates how white you are
whiteness is unfalsifiable it is
undeniable you are you're defined by
your whiteness because Robyn D'Angelo
says you are okay so that is problem
number two is the is the bizarre
redefinition of racism in which racism
is institutional structures it has
nothing to with you personally except
that you're guilty for all of it okay
this brings us to point number three the
Robyn D'Angelo makes okay and that is
that American systems suck America sucks
this is a real point right it's really a
Marxist critique is that America the
16:19 project as it says rooted in evil
racism bigotry white supremacy and the
real indicators of bigotry and white
supremacy today are things like belief
in individualism if you believe that
individuals are responsible for their
decision-making and you don't blame
racism for all inequality of outcome
that means you're a racist so if you
look at two people and they have unequal
outcomes and you don't say oh that was
discrimination or racism it's because
you're a racist in some way and she
quotes Abram candy to this effect
she says candy goes on to argue that if
we truly believe that all humans are
equal disparity and condition can only
be the result of systemic discrimination
okay that again is a crazy contention no
two human beings on planet Earth have
the same conditions the same living
conditions children within the same
households have different living
conditions is that the result of
systemic discrimination to view human
beings this way is completely a
scientific and bizarre but individualism
is the real enemy here because if you
see somebody else as an individual along
the lines of Martin Luther King jr.
espoused you're actually promoting
racism is what she says because the
individualism suggests that you are
responsible for your own actions which
means that maybe if you fail is not
everybody else's fault and the
precondition of racism is that it is
everybody else's fault it's the
society's fault and if you fail to
recognize this then you are a racist
so she says this individualism claims
that there are no intrinsic barriers to
individual success and that failure is
not a consequence of social structures
but comes from individual character
according to the ideology of
individualism race is irrelevant
regardless of our prata stations that
social groups don't matter and that we
see everyone is equal we know that to be
a man as defined by the dominant culture
is a different experience than being a
woman these groups matter but they don't
matter naturally as we are often taught
to believe rather we are taught that
they matter and the social meaning
ascribed to these groups creates a
difference in lived experience okay so
now she's even contradicting herself
this isn't even internally coherent
right she's suggesting that
individualism is bad because you might
blame people for their social condition
and not the system right you might blame
people based on the fact that they are
individuals but also these social
conditions are figments of the
imagination so which is it is race real
or is race not real if race is not real
then perhaps the way we overcome racism
is by focusing in on the individual but
no you can't focus in on the individual
because then he won't blame racism all
right so it contradicts itself here and
she just blithely moves past that right
we're all individuals and race isn't
real except that race is super real and
defines all of our interactions but we
can't overcome that by teaching people
to think as individuals so we have to
buy into the fake concept of race in
order to get past racism square that
circle if you can okay the the next
idiotic points in this ridiculous stupid
book white fragility by Robyn D'Angelo
we've gone through three already the
historical nonsense the bizarre
redefinition of racism where racism is
everything in all things ripping on
American systems like individualism
meritocracy she says objectivity is also
an aspect of racism if you say your
objective about an issue you can't be
objective because your race defines you
so she's gonna have to explain that to
the scientific method by the way it's
also undeniable right if you if you deny
any of this if you have a positive
self-image then this as a white person
this means that you are racist so you're
not even allowed to protest I'm not a
racist it's pretty amazing
she says denying that we have few cross
racial relationships by proclaiming how
diverse our community or workplaces or
attributing inequality between whites
and people of color to causes other than
racism is enacting racism racism is
everything and it's undeniable and if
you give alternative explanations for
disparities that's because you're racist
already folks we'll get back to this in
just a second I got to tell you about
Ray Khan Ray Khan makes fantastic
fantastic here but one of the reasons
they're so terrific is they come with a
variety of fits just for your ears so
unlike a lot of other wireless earbuds
you know the ones that are sort of one
size fits all these ones come with an
actual card that has a variety of fits
they come with it so you can actually
customize that check this out it just
flew into me it just flew into me if you
actually take a look at the rake on
wireless earbuds they come along with
this right here right a variety of fits
you can actually customize it so it fits
your ear absolutely perfectly also it
comes in a variety of colors variety of
styles so they're really cool go check
out the Ray cons right now they are the
best wireless earbuds on the market and
they sound just as good as all the other
earbuds and they started half the price
plus you get 15% off your order today
from the everyday e 25 year but those
two the best model yet six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass more compact design that gives you
that nice noise isolating fit every
single day I pop these babies out pop
them in my ear and spend half the day
with ray cons in my ears specifically
because I'm listening to you so much
content I know you are too these days
again head on over to buy recon comm
slash Shapiro whitey that's by rake on
comm slash Shapiro whitey click the link
in the description below to get 15% off
your order again go ahead and get 15%
off your order
by clicking on that description in the
link below I know that you will enjoy
your Ray cons as much as I do okay this
brings us to our fourth point her own
arrogance the arrogance of white
centrality the only people who matter on
planet earth are white woke leftist
they're the only people who matter there
are the greatest human beings who have
ever been created these white woke
leftists they are here too
try to other people who are white for
not being sufficiently sufficiently woke
and they are here to take care of all of
the poor black people who require the
help of Robyn D'Angelo and have no
autonomy of their own and have no agency
of their own I mean she really deprives
black people of agency in this book it's
incredibly incredibly racist
so she says stuff like this quote in
speaking as a white person to a
primarily white audience I am yet again
centering white people on the white
voice I have not found a way around this
dilemma though I am centering the white
voice I am also using my insider status
to challenge racism to not use my
position this way is to uphold racism
and that is unacceptable
she's the start of the story she's the
end of the story she's the only person
who matters in the story
racism is because of white people which
means that only white people have the
power to help black people which means
only Robyn D'Angelo matters and this is
how you end up with that amazing clip of
the of the white woman yelling a black
police officer and saying that she has
something to say about racism but the
black police officer doesn't really have
anything to say about racism I have a
question for you you're white and you're
telling this to two black police
officers you see the problem with that a
little bit oh no I don't because you
know what don't because I'm white and I
have an experience racism myself doesn't
mean I can't fight for justice she says
quote I believe that white progressives
caused the most daily damage to people
of color I had to find a white
progressive is any white person who
thinks he or she is not racist or is
less racist or in the choir or already
gets it by the way she does not count
her something is white progressive right
obviously she gets it but not you you
don't get it even if you say you get it
if you say you get it you're a white
progressive and you are the biggest
problem not a problem for black people
the biggest problem for black people
according to Robyn Angelou which is
again the most patronizing asked in most
patronizing ridiculous angle to our
black people ever she says white
progressives can be the most difficult
for people of color because to the
degree we think we have arrived we will
put our energy into making sure that
others see us as having arrived okay
that's that's unfalsifiable insane
nonsense the only way you know you're a
racist is if you think you are not so if
you say I'm not a racist you're a racist
and if you say you are a racist you are
also a racist so which sinks or floats
doesn't matter which dies right that's
it that's the way this works if you say
I'm not a racist and I read Brahmins
Angela's white fertility you
demonstrating white fragility also if
you are a racist at least you're
acknowledging the error racist which
means that maybe you're not a racist but
you just admitted your races so you're
kind of racist she does this routine
where she suggests that you can't talk
to black people about racism but also
unless you ask a black person about
racism you're doing it wrong
so she says at one point the expectation
that people of color should teach white
people about racism is another aspect of
white racial innocence that reinforces
several problematic racial assumptions
like why haven't we sought out
information on this before this
conversation um so basically she says
you're not oh you don't know anything
about racism cuz you're white right your
own whiteness prevents you from seeing
race properly and also you can't act ask
a black person about racism because that
would be assuming that they speak for
all black people so there's only one
person you can ask about racism
ironically enough who could it possibly
be who could you possibly go to as your
guide oh yeah yeah Robin Angela you
could pay her some money for diversity
training okay this brings us to point
number five and that is treating black
people as tokens I've mentioned this
already treating black people is
completely ineffective as unable to
control their own lives the way she
talks about black people is insane I
mean totally totally crazy she says
quote our simplistic definition of
racism as intentional acts of racial
discrimination committed by immoral
individuals engenders a confidence that
we are not part of the problem and that
our learning is thus complete the claims
we offer up as evidence are implausible
for example perhaps you've heard someone
say I was taught to treat everyone the
same or people just need to be taught to
respect one another and that begins in
the home these statements are
unconvincing to most people of color and
only invalidate their experiences
apparently if you say to a black person
I was taught to treat everyone the same
black people look at you cross-eyed
apparently apparently no black person
has ever been taught in their home to
treat people the same or the people need
to respect each other I have a feeling
that's not true I have feeling lots and
lots of black people across America
teach their children in their home to
respect each other in the home and
beyond
but according to Robyn D'Angelo no black
person's ever been taught that and if
you say that then obviously black people
will look at you as though you're crazy
this has she thinks of black people
she's talking about white tears okay in
white woman's tears she suggests that
white woman's tears are dangerous white
woman's tears are dangerous why are
white woman's tears dangerous because in
the past if a white woman cried maybe
she was crying because she was falsely
accusing
man of rape like a man tell case or a
sexual assault
like the Emmett Till case and then maybe
the black person will be victimized
because the white lady's crying okay I'm
not kidding this is what she says in her
book quote as the meeting started
I told my fellow white participants that
if they felt moved to tears they should
please leave the room
I would go with them for support but I
asked that they not cry in the mixed
group after the discussion I spent the
next hour explaining to a very outraged
white woman why she was asked not to cry
in the presence of the people of color
there is a long historical backdrop of
black men being tortured and murdered
because of a white woman's distress and
we white women bring these histories
with us our tears trigger the Terrorism
of this history particularly for African
Americans has she met a black person how
many black people when they see a white
woman crying go oh my god I'm about to
be lynched
how many seriously like any like what
what what has she does she know black
people worth robbing the Angela this is
crazy talk she says she herself about
her own crime she says she cries in
these sessions but quote I tried to
quite quietly so I don't take up more
space and if people rush to comfort me I
do not accept the comfort I let them
know I am fine so we can move on by the
way she says that if men of color try to
try to help white women they may be
driven by their conditioning so if
you're a black person who tries to help
a white woman it's because you have
integrated into your own life the white
supremacy quote men of color may also
come to the aid of white women in these
exchanges and may also be driven by
their conditioning under sexism and
patriarchy right they've internalized
the patriarchy and they maybe they're
acting from sexism wow wow wow wow I
mean like this is crazy by the way she
also suggests that if you have a black
friend and you're not talking with your
black friend about race maybe your
friendship isn't real like all she is
there to do Robins Angelou is make race
relations worse I think all she does is
go into rooms like a but imagine how
black people feel when like you're in a
room into diversity training and Robbins
Angelou turns to all the white people
says do not cry in front of those black
people don't do it don't cry in front of
those black people cuz if you cry in
front of those black people they're
gonna feel like you're gonna Lynch them
as a black person does that make you
feel more or less comfortable what in
the actual hell this is I'm not making
this up guys this is in the best-selling
book in America featured on Jimmy Fallon
okay then we get to these
problem.the unfalsifiable ax T and the
cultish nonsense the more that you deny
the the insanity of Robyn D'Angelo the
more you suffer from white fragility
it's incredible
the more you dissent from her point of
view that just indicates that you are
suffering from white fragility right
this is catch-22 if you are healthy
enough to not want to fly then that
means that you're healthy enough to fly
and if you're crazy enough to want to
fly then that means that we should let
you fly right it's catch-22 it's just
even no matter it no matter how you do
this this is where you know ok
unfalsifiable 'ti and call session onset
and it's just in semi ins throughout the
book quote the white fragility is
triggered by discomfort and anxiety it
is born of superiority and entitlement
in fact it is a powerful means of white
racial control and the protection of
white advantage so if you're white
you're part of a racist system if you
feel discomfort in anxiety someone's
calling you a racist that's because you
are a racist quote how can I say that if
you are white your opinions on racism
are most likely ignorant when I don't
even know you I can say so because
nothing in mainstream US culture gives
us the information we need to have the
nuanced understanding of arguably the
most complex and enduring social dynamic
of the last seven hundred years so again
the cult leader will inform you of the
of the fascinating details of white
privilege she says in fact when we try
to talk openly and honestly about race
white fragility emerges as we are so
often met with silence defensive Nosara
mentation certitude in other forms of
pushback these are not natural responses
there are social forces that prevent us
from attaining the racial knowledge we
need so she says something crazy and you
say that sounds like to me
if that happens then you are just that's
not you and it's not that she's spouting
it's that there are social
forces preventing us from attaining the
racial knowledge we need all you have to
do is take these clear lessons and we
can cleanse the thetans from you it's
social forces acting upon you
what are these forces they include the
ideologies of individualism and
meritocracy narrow and repetitive media
representations of people of color
depictions of whiteness is the human
ideal white solidarity she talks about
if you lack racial humility and you are
unwilling to listen or if you want to
get to solutions or if you want to focus
on intentions over impact meaning that
you actually want intent of racism as
opposed to just evidence of inequality
all of this is racism she says that if
you claim you are colorblind or if you
color celebrate right if you say that
you're married to a black person or you
have lots of black friends or you
marched for it so
all rights in the 60s all that's bad
because it takes race off the table and
clothes rather than open any further
exploration
she says that respect assumption of good
intentions and refusing to make
assumptions are all called out as signs
as what of white fragility okay
basically bottom line is no matter what
you do you're racist unless Robyn
Angelou gives you the clean bill of
health and then she gives crazy examples
of her of her philosophy in action and
this is the most fun part quote consider
a conversation I had with a white friend
she was telling me about a white couple
she knew who had just moved to New
Orleans and bought a house for a mere
twenty five thousand dollars of course
she immediately added they also had to
buy a gun and Jonah's afraid to leave
the house I immediately knew they bought
a home in a black neighborhood who is
the racist here exactly Robyn D'Angelo
why is it that you immediately go to it
must be a black neighborhood and why is
it that even if it is a majority black
neighborhood that is the deciding
feature why is your immediate assumption
that the person doesn't want to live
there because it's filled with black
people as opposed to what they are
saying I don't want to live there
because it's filled with crime I mean
that's like overtly racist stuff there
from Robyn D'Angelo and she's
proclaiming that this is because of her
own woke Ness another great example to
illustrate an early lesson in white
racial framing imagine that a white
mother and her white child her in the
grocery store the child sees a black man
and shouts out mommy that man's skin is
black several people including the black
man's firm to look how do you imagine
the mother would respond most people
would immediately put their finger to
their mouth and say shush when white
people are asked what the mother might
be feeling most agree she is likely to
feel anxiety tension and embarrassment
indeed many of us have had similar
experiences wherein the message was
clear we should not talk openly about
race now imagine the child had shouted
out how handsome the man was or how
strong these statements would probably
be meant with chuckles and smiles the
child would not likely be touched
because we consider these statements
complements okay um question isn't the
real reason that the white woman is
saying shush to the child because she's
afraid that she's going to offend the
black guy isn't that the real reason
that she's saying shush to the child hey
isn't it it's not because she thinks
that black is a diss it is because she
is afraid the black man will be offended
by the fact that the child is pointing
out race okay and maybe she was afraid
of that because people like Rob and
Angela are going around saying that
black people are easily triggered by
everything on earth apparently and they
need Robyn D'Angelo specific protection
maybe the mother is being oversensitive
because she has been trained to be
oversensitive by people like Robin to
Angela is that possible
no it has to be that the white mother is
experiencing racism hey here's another
great story okay so there's a teacher
and the teacher said to to a couple of
white to a couple of girls one was white
and one was black they finished a phrase
with you should do this girl and the
black girl got very offended very very
offended and ascended with like actual
litigation and so Robyn D'Angelo was
brought in to fix it she said these
white teachers responses illustrate
several dynamics of white fragility so
what happened is the white girl said
well the teacher calls everybody girl
like she calls me girl she called the
black girl girl there's nothing
offensive about that she calls everybody
girl in the same way that my father will
very often call people sweetheart he
does this all the time right it's it
doesn't mean he doesn't direct it and
that women of a particular age or
particular Creed right it's just it's
just an endearment right then the same
thing happens here where the teacher
calls everybody girl and the black girl
gets offended and then the teacher says
I don't understand why people are
getting offended literally I call this -
everybody hears Robins Angelo's take
these white teachers responses
illustrate several dynamics of white
fragility they were unable to separate
intentions from impact despite the
teachers lack of cross-racial skills and
understanding a lack that led to a
racial violation with potential legal
repercussions he arrogantly remained
confident that he was right and that the
student was wrong see as soon as you
protest your innocence as soon as you
say I wasn't saying anything racist in
fact it's that's a word I use with
everybody now you're suffering from
white fragility because you have made
your intense the question here okay if
all of this sounds like a cult that's
because it is a called the Robins Angela
white fragility cult is a cult and the
only way to become an initiate into the
cult is to buy into everything the Robyn
D'Angelo says to buy her book to buy her
diversity program and then to browbeat
yourself until you reach the final level
of the cult at the final level of the
cult is where you just become a walking
spouting Robyn D'Angelo lecturing black
police officers about the white legacy
of racism in the United States this is
all crazy it's all nuts and the fact
that it's the number one best-selling
book in America says a lot about where
we are in this moment it is not good for
the country it makes the country
significantly significantly worse do not
buy this book I bought it for you just
so you would not have to read it do not
give this grifter your money don't do it
but if you want to buy the rejoinder -
this book if you want to recognize what
it is that is being destroyed why the
greatest system in human history is
being destroyed the philosophy culture
the
three of the united states why all these
things are being destroyed by Robyn
D'Angelo by my book instead July 21st it
comes out how to destroy America in
three easy steps never has been more
relevant it is I think the the end of
the story in terms of rebutting a lot of
this nonsense it'll certainly help you
around the water cooler and will remind
you of why America is such a great and
good country how to destroy America in
three easy steps go check it out right
now that's what all I got to say on
white fragility I feel like it's plenty
if you liked this content and you would
enjoy seeing more like it make sure that
you like this video and then comment
below